you don't want that so session is
tomorrow through the first morning it
will be on context bandits yes okay
thank you very much for the introduction
very happy to be here so I will tell you
about bandit convex optimization so let
me go straight ahead into it because I
have a lot of things that I want to tell
you so the program goes like this let's
say we are given K of convex body neuron
so this is a convex set with non-empty
interior and compact and we're going to
play a sequential games which goes like
this
at every time step pro time step T
equals 1 to capital G with no capital T
we as a player we select a point in this
convex body ok so that's the action that
we play we play a point in this convex
body and simultaneously there is an
adversary's that chooses a loss function
on this convex body and we are going to
assume that this loss is convex okay so
the adversary chooses the loss energy
from k201
we also assume that the losses are
bounded and the player what what the
player suffers is the loss evaluated at
the point that was played so the loss L
T of X T and that's also the only
feedback that the player received on
what the adversary did okay so we are
the only thing we know about LT is a G
of X T and our measure of performance is
the regret so the regret goes like this
we look at how much we have lost okay so
the sum for T equals 1 to capital T of L
G of X since that's how much we have
lost and we compare our self to the best
we could have done in hindsight
with a fixed point so we compare
yourself to the mean for X in K
some 40 equals 1 to capital G over G of
X and we take the expectation of all of
this the expectation is over the
randomization of the player so the
player can choose the point XT at random
okay I will assume and I know by looking
at you that this is an audience of
expert so I will not motivate this
program I will not tell you what a
regret means and all of this I hope
you're all familiar with that what I
want to tell you is how to solve this
problem my personal interest in this
problem doesn't come from real
application but it more comes from I
want to understand how much you can do
with the bandit feedback ok the bandit
feedback is when you observe just a
scalar value which is just your own loss
ok how much can you do with this small
feedback ok so this program has a long
history and I'm going to spend I don't
know three four minutes on this so this
program was initiated by Bobby Kleinberg
who is in the room in 2004 in the
seminal paper where he showed that the
regret can be as small as T to the 3/4
and from 10 years until the core paper
we had with run and L done a year ago
this was the state of the art bound for
this general setting okay so nothing
better was known for this problem until
2015 and all the papers in between what
they do is that they make further
assumptions yes but they say in these
papers that they improve your your good
so we so so these so the other paper the
paper that came right after all at the
same time is Flaxman Kelly McMann and
they also get T to the 3/4 and did the
Uyghurs and there is very thin very
simple what you do is you just do
gradient descent so of course you don't
know the gradient of the losses so what
you do is you do a one point estimate of
the gradient I won't talk about that
this is well-known and most of the
papers I try to improve on this strategy
what we will do is something completely
different so among the the interesting
things that happen in between was the
linear case
which is now completely solved so there
were two paper by Danny is and Kakashi
and Abernathy as an interacting in 2008
what they showed is that in the linear
case you can get cruelty so square root
T is the optimal things that that you
can get and that the target and the
dependency of the dimension was n to the
three half later we improved it with
Niko low chatter monkey and sham caca d2
n Square t and n Square t is the best
you can do so there was also a lower
bound the results which are in red are
the current state of the art okay so for
the linear case this is the best you can
do let me mention a paper by alec acaba
jean foster daniels ushanka kadhi and
sasha Rocklin from 2011 where the loss
is LTR iid so it's this setting but the
loss is our ID and they can chose
quality and the dependency of the
dimension is n to the 16 okay so when
the loss is iid the problem is in some
ways much simpler okay because you there
is a clear thing to learn when the loss
is unknown iid it's more difficult then
other papers include improvement when
you have strong convexity of the losses
smoothness of the losses this paper was
two years ago with offered a Cal Tom
McCarron within the room and you bell
Paris where we showed that in dimension
one you can actually get quality okay so
dimension one is just one someone
further assumption on the problem and
this bond was information theoretic so
what we showed is we didn't give an
explicit algorithm but we use the
minimax principle and then we analyzed
the dual biasion problem and in the dual
we were able to use a variant of
Thompson sampling and this paper in 2015
is in an extension of this to any
dimension okay so this was the past is
the first paper showing that you can do
body dimension times quality for this
problem but without giving any algorithm
so at this point after this paper the
computational complexity of this problem
was exponential both in time and in the
dimension then six months later there
was a paper by era season and only from
in March 2016 where they showed that you
can get exponential in the dimension
times quality and the computational
complexity is also exponential in the
dimension but
L&T okay so this is worse than this
result in the sense that the dependency
of the dimension is exponential but at
least it's a concrete algorithm and what
I will tell you about today is this
paper with run and I'll done and in
totleigh where we show n to the 9.5
scrotie with an efficient algorithm any
question on this slide okay so now I
will move to the Bob and let me yes yes
so I will come to this but my conjecture
is n to the three half we don't have
there our bound we don't have the upper
bound I think with an efficient
algorithm yes even the information
theoretically we don't know so the best
way we know is this n to the 9.5 okay so
let me start with a lemma that everybody
in the room knows so this is the lemma
for exponential weights so let L 1 up to
LT be loss functions from k2 r plus okay
so these are non-negative losses and let
me define the probability measure PT
plus 1 by induction so PT plus 1 the
density so I'm going to always confuse
densities measures low all of these I
will use the same notation to not
overload thing so PT plus 1 attacks
really means g PT plus 1 over G X so
this is going to be proportional to P G
of x times exponential minus ETA L G of
X so at I is some learning rate P G of X
is a previous priority we add at this
point and we decrease it by that much
okay and this see this sign proportional
means up to a constant okay and the
constant is so that PT plus 1 integrates
to 1 okay so if we define this like this
then we have the following
let me give also two notations so I will
use the inner product between F and G
sorry yeah I know but I will use them so
not worry it will get filled up so the
inner product F G in l2 okay so this is
in
of F time she and I also need the
relative entropy of F with respect to G
so this is the integral of F log F over
G okay just need those two notations so
then we've these two notations we have
the following so if we look at the Sun
for T equals 1 to capital T of PT minus
Q L T so what this means is the sum of
PT L T that's our loss integrated that
our expected loss when we play a point
from PT and ql t is the loss we would
have obtained if we had planed at every
one from Q so Q you should think of it
as a as a point mass on some point ok
the optimal point at Z so this is upper
bounded by the relative entropy of Q to
P one minus the relative entropy of Q to
PT plus one divided by the runnin right
plus beta times the Sun for T equals 1
to capital T of PT LT squared so this is
to be understood as a variance term and
this is a term that depends on the size
of the set basically okay and I use I
will use in this top we will use the
minus term here this would be very
important in about 40 minutes also okay
good so we are we are all good with with
this term so let's see some applications
of it just to get a feel for it so let's
say we do full information
okay so full informations means we
actually observe the LT and let's assume
that the LT are now in 0 1 with a G of X
in 0 1 and L T's Lipchitz
then what we get is that our regret is
bounded up to some constant so let's see
system so the relative entropy is always
positive so we just have the first term
the rate of entropy of Q 2 P 1 in the
definition of the regret we compare
ourselves to the best fixed point okay
here if you put a fixed point this
relative entropy term goes to infinity
so let's take you to be a small the
uniform measure on a small ball around
the best point this doesn't change too
much I regret because I assume that LT
is Lipschitz
okay so Q can be a very small ball and
relative entropy of the uniform measure
on the whole set with respect to a small
ball this is something like n Times log
T okay this is a very easy calculation
it just has to do with volume I won't do
it
so you get n log T over etta now the
variance term since the ltr' in 0 1 this
variance is 1 at most so we get attached
e+ itachi so if you optimize over etta
you see that you get the square root of
the product okay so this is bounded by
square root of n t log t this is without
any assumption right without any
convexity with nothing okay so let's do
enough another thing a little bit more
challenging
let's do linear bandit and any the
dimension it's it's erased now but n was
the dimension sorry that it is yes
lot of entropy cube with p1 radius
yeah of course it does so yes so let me
assume that the diameter of K is polity
anything polynomially it just shouldn't
be exponential then it will appear in
this so if it's polity is just a
constant okay so let's do Lena bandit so
Linda bandit means that energy of X so
this is a linear function so it's LT
times X okay and I'm going to assume
again the normalization that this is in
the robot and that's the only thing we
observe okay so in this case we cannot
place the exponential wedge distribution
because we don't know what is a tip so
what we do what we have been doing since
Danny is and Kakadu is to all even
before is to put an unbiased estimator
of the rows in this case there is a very
natural thing to do which is a one-point
linear regression so what does it mean
it just means we set LT t to be the
following so let's say we play XT from
PT and we pray XT from PT and let me
denote by Sigma T the covariance matrix
so Sigma T is the expectation when X is
drawn from PT of X 3x C transpose X X
transpose sorry okay let me use another
bond so these are the notation now I'm
going to define the loss estimate or LTV
t is going to be the following sigma t
minus 1 xt xt transpose LT okay so this
I can calculate X C transpose L T is my
actual loss this is what I have suffered
Sigma Chi and XC XC is the point that I
play it's Sigma Chi is a covariance I
can calculate it so I can compute this
now it's easy to see write that in
expectation with respect to X G and T T
what is it so this doesn't depend on X
it doesn't depend on X is expectation of
X T X T transpose is Sigma T it cancels
with a sigma t minus 1 and I get LT ok
so this is an unbiased estimator so I
can run exponential weights with this
activity what do I get my regret is
going to be bounded by ok I get again
this n of T term over a top plus now I
get the sum for T equals 1 to capital T
of the expectation
PT x 18 t squared okay let's look at
what this is so this is I can rewrite it
as the expectation when X is drawn from
PT of energy T transpose x squared okay
so this is a scalar so it's the same
thing as X transpose HD T so I can write
this as delta T transpose X X transpose
delta T xx transpose in expectation is
Sigma T so this is equal to L 2 3 times
Sigma T times activity what is empty did
this thing right so XJ transpose RT it's
I can bound it by 1 okay let's say by
Luis this is and say this thing is in
minus 1 1 sorry so so XG transpose del T
squared is bounded by 1 okay so what I'm
left with is Sigma T minus 1 X T so you
see one of the Sigma T minus 1 cancels
with this Sigma T minus 1 and I get that
this is bounded by X T transpose sigma t
minus 1 XT which is the same thing as
the trace of sigma t minus 1 xt xt
transpose when i take the expectation
with respect to x g this is Sigma T so
it cancels with sigma t minus 1 and I
get n the dimension okay so it's the
expectation so what we get now we can
come back to here this is bounded by so
we get this n log t over at ax plus
again I said that in expectation this is
going to be the dimension so we get n t+
and there was a time missing plus beta
and T so when I optimize over Etta I get
the regret is bounded by n square root T
lochte
so I get an extra square root 10
compared to the full information case
we're good with this calculation okay so
now this is you know at least this
calculation is eight years old
let me say just here that you need to be
a little bit careful I use this bound
but this bond was proved only for losses
which are positive
okay non-negative but this loss
estimator can be negative and this
actually causes a lot of troubles okay
so there is a little bit more going on
here but let me ignore this fact for the
moment all for this talk okay so the
question is really in the convex case
what is an unbiased estimator so what is
LTTE when LG is convex
there was a very natural estimator for
the dinner case but there is a purely no
natural estimator for the convex case
and this is why there was no progress
during ten years okay so let me tell you
the new idea okay it came after a long
time of work so it will appear maybe it
will not be obvious how we got there but
you will see that it's very simple so
let K be a linear operator so this will
be my corner on measures say on
probability measure
and I'm going to look at Turner's which
can be written in the following way so k
q @x so what does this notation mean q
is a probability measure KQ is a linear
operator applied to Q K Q at X is the
density of this measure with respect to
the rebec measure at the point X and I
want this to be able to write it like
the integral of KX y qy dy okay so here
there is an abuse of notation where I'm
using K both to denote the linear
operator and to denote somehow its
density
okay so again this is just to simplify
things I hope this equation is clear by
given a function K which is defined on
on the contacts body times the contacts
body this defines a linear operator good
so - I have such an in our burrito I
also have an adjoint so the adjoint in L
2 is K star F so K star H now I will
think of it as applied to functions so K
star F at some point Y this is the
integral of F of Y sorry f of X K of X Y
DX okay and it's the adjoint because if
I do let's say KQ times F this is by
definite by those definition this is
equal to Q K star F these are just
notations okay there is a lot going on
in those small notation but these are
just notation good so now here is the
magic K star F really the way to think
about it is that it's the integral of f
of X K of X dot G X so the way to think
about K star F is that it's a
superposition of different functions of
the from K X dot where the weight of
each function K X dot is given by the
value of f at X so this is exactly this
is appropriate for bandit because now in
the bandit case if we just observe f of
X we have a very natural
and biased estimator for K star F can
you just do f of X times K X dot okay so
let me say that again
so given f of X with X sample from some
probability measure Q we have that f of
X normalized by the density Q at X times
K of X dot is an unbiased estimator
miss tomato of case-knife
okay right so I mean okay yeah of course
of course yes it is it is a special case
so I mean if you want to use big words
you can say that this is like a bandit
Fourier transform okay but but right now
it doesn't mean anything because what is
K star F okay in the end I we need to
relate I will be able to what I'm going
to tell you right now is using such an
unbiased estimator you control your
regret with respect to K star applied to
your losses but what you want is control
the regret with respect to the two
losses okay let me say that again
so let's see so say XT is played from
some probability measure QT and let L
till t be well my loss L G of X T over Q
T of XT times some kernel K T of X G dot
okay so I write k t because the kernel
is going to change over time it will be
obvious that you cannot have a fixed
kernel beforehand you need to have an
adaptive Connor
so let's say we do this and we take PG
is the exponential weight distribution
on Delta T and P T exponential weight on
L 2 T okay so what we control what do we
control with the lemma we control PG
minus Q times K star LT right one thing
I didn't say I hope it was obvious if I
put an LT t in this lemma when I take
the expectation right if the expectation
of LT is Lt then I'm all good okay on
the left hand side I have exactly this
term and on the right hand side I have
system with certainty
yes so Katie has not been defined yet
Katie is going to be a kernel that I
choose at time step T so the kernel is
going to depend on on the past
uh sorry it's K stop T yes thanks okay
so with the lemma we control regret of
this form which is of course K T applied
to PT minus Q times LT but we want
well we want we want let's see we want
QT minus Q times LT let me play from QT
so QT x LT is our actual loss so that's
what we want to control and with respect
to q q is some measure defined
beforehand okay so that's what we want
to control but what we get to control on
with the lemma is this term fine fine so
we need that what we want is that this
term is controlled by this one so we
want QT minus Q times LT to be
controlled by this
so so you can take QT to be PT but then
it's still there is a difference between
PT minus Q times RT and Katie PT minus Q
times Mt
another question of T then you already
taken you took a read expectation yeah
of course here I already took
expectation yes here the first term yes
the first thing to see which so when I
say we control what I mean is we have
this lemma so I will need to deal with
this vans term of course and really here
if I was going a little bit more slowly
what I would need to what I would write
is PT minus Q times n tilde G but then
when I take the expectation the
expectation of l TT is KT storagee
now I have not defined it okay so let me
say what is QT so when you see this we
want to control that but we control this
is natural to take QT to be Katy PT
natural take Q T equals K TPT then we
need
what we need is a Katy PT minus Q times
LT to be bounded up to some constant by
Katy PT minus Q times LT and there is
something pretty
I don't know deep a profound or delicate
going on in this inequality okay and we
will see how to verify it it's at least
to me it's impossible to think about
what this means okay it's it's it's
really complicated but let's see an
example so this is a new thing that we
introduced which we called generalized
Bernoulli convolutions I will tell you
what is a binary convolution yes
so one difficulty is that this is only
one side of the story the other side of
the story is going to be the vent so yes
of course you can find things where this
is true just take K to be the identity
if K is the identities and you can take
QT to be PT and that's it no so then no
then I don't know I don't know but in
any case this again this is only one
side there will be two sides to it and
the variance will be important okay so
generalize beyond ORAC convolution so
let's see let's rewrite this so what we
want so we want okay so let me drop the
T and Q is going to be a point mass so
we want KP minus Delta x times f to be
bounded up to a constant by K P minus
Delta X F and let's say the constant I
write it as 1 over lambda
it's it's just one line of algebra let's
not do it to see that this is equivalent
to saying that K Delta X F so we want
this for a convex function f is bounded
by 1 minus lambda KP f plus lambda f of
X ok so this is just completely
equivalent so if you stare at this for
long enough then there is a natural
kernel that comes out so the natural
kernel is to take a kernel K such that K
Delta X is equal in distribution ok you
can think of this as a distribution this
is equal to 1 minus lambda some random
variable Z plus lambda X for some random
variable Z
that depends on people
the colonel K is going to depend on P
with the current exponential weights
okay so is this is this notation clear
so the colonel when I apply it to a
point mass what it does is that it takes
a random variable Z and then it puts
itself on the segment between Z and X at
the distance lambda
okay put itself at 1 minus lambda Z plus
lambda X Y is this natural so let's see
this guy so let's call this stuff then
what do we get so K which is K Delta XF
that just means the expectation when I
sample from this of F at this point so
by convexity this is bounded by 1 minus
lambda F of Z F of Z plus lambda f of X
by convexity of F and this is the
crucial moment where convexity is used
almost the only one
because we want this to apply it for any
convex loss at the end of the day okay
so we get this but we want star so we
want F of Z F of Z to be bounded by K P
F so in particular we get star if Z is
equal to K P so we get star
we get star if Z is equal to KP what is
KP KP is 1 minus lambda Z plus lambda X
where X is sampled from P so this is
sort of a circular definition ok the
definition of Z is some kind of
self-similar equation in just the
picture is like this so this is Z let's
say you sample from Z so if I take a
sample from Z ok and I take a sample
from X this is X and I put myself at 1
minus lambda Z plus lambda X so this is
1 minus lambda Z plus lambda X then I
want this point to still be distributed
according to Z we call this the core of
P we call Z the coffee
it always exists and its unique what is
it exactly Z is just the sum for K
equals 0 to infinity of 1 minus lambda
to the K lambda X K where the x KR i ad
from p
it's clear because now if I do one minus
lambda times this I just shift the index
from K equals one to infinity and then
if I add lambda X I add the term zero
okay so this Z exactly satisfies this
and it's the unique one
okay so just see just a minute of
history so if you take P to be a random
a cur
this was defined in the 30s and it's
called the Bernoulli convolution so the
core of a Rademacher
so rather maker is just plus one thirty
one half minus one over T one half so
the coffeemaker is a Bernoulli
convolution and just a few results there
are hundreds of papers on this to get
some intuition about this let's think
about it so if lambda is in one half one
then you see that this thing is going to
be supported on the Cantor set okay
let's see let's say lambda is is 2/3
then I get 1/3 to the K okay I just say
where I am in this Cantor set
I'm just describing a point in this
Cantor set so for lambda in 1/2 1 Z is
singular with respect to the lebesgue
measure so for lambda in this Z is
singular and it's understood singular
with respect to the lebesgue measure on
the other hand Erdos in 39 proved that
there is an infinity of singular lambda
in zero 1/2 so you could you what you
think the intuition should be that when
lambda gets smaller
this becomes smoother and smoother okay
because you're forgetting more about the
initial condition if you want you're
always pushing more mass towards
infinity the other said okay be careful
it's essentially true as we've seen emit
but not quite so there is an infinity of
singular lambda in zero one half but it
proved in the 40s and this was
generalized by solo MEAC in 96 that
almost every lambda in 0 1/2 is
absolutely continuous so for almost
every lambda is your one-half this thing
is absolutely continuous which is a
measure of smoothness and but but there
are many counter examples so there are
number 70 construction to this
smoothness one thing also that I can say
is if there are specific values of
lambda which are of order let's say 1
over K such that this density when it's
absolutely continuous is ck ok it's K
times differentiable so if lambda is
very small then it's really smooth so
which is this intuition coming back to
us and what's important for us is at the
core of a Gaussian well that's a
Gaussian right just taking a convolution
so the core of a Gaussian is a Gaussian
with just different standard deviations
or or vents
nonde over to minus lambda
any question so now I'm going to take
the kernel associated to this Co and
what I need to do is to control the
bands okay so now I I need to ask
Barrens control
yes yeah so exactly so that's what we're
I'm getting at
yes so this is just this part is just
for intuition this part is much closer
to what we will really need so I won't
show it's close to the ocean I will do
something else it would be nice but okay
so the variance control just say convex
yes yes so okay so that's a good
question I should maybe I've said that
at the very beginning so yes if you have
food information the worst case is if
the adversary plays linear' losses
because you know you can always say okay
he played this convex loss and I played
at this point but in fact if you had
played the linear function that goes
through this point then the loss at
every other point would have been
smaller okay so the adversary would have
been better off by playing linear
functions okay in the Bandit case you
cannot say that because there is a game
of information so if I know that the
adversary is playing linear functions
then I can do one point in our
regression but if I don't know that the
adversary is playing in a function then
I cannot do one point in our regression
so to prove so I said at the beginning
that I conjecture the optimal regret is
n to the three-halves Kruti the current
best lower bound is n squirty to prove a
lower bound of n to the three-halves
curity you would have to show
mathematically what i just said that the
adversary has an advantage in playing a
convex function you can trade off losses
for information but I don't know to
formalize this so the kernel what it's
doing is that it swapping space so
basically saying right now I have my
exponential weight distribution I know
that what matters is some region of
space and far from it it doesn't matter
what's really happening so the kernel
what is doing is that it's rescaling
space so that this little thing looks
like everything but since it was little
so
convex function is essentially linear in
this linear in this small piece so there
is something so we we cannot formalize
this but there is a sense in which the
kernel is allowing you to get back to
the linear case that's one intuition
okay but really the honest truth on how
we found it is you just look at this
equation and okay if you if you in this
business for long enough it jumps at you
that okay this is a very good situation
for the bandit case okay so the variance
variance control so what I want to say
is this so assume two things one that P
is a Gaussian this is not true and I
will explain how to remove this
assumption and two that the support of P
is bounded sort of peas in some ball
centered at zero and off reduce our of
course if your Gaussian your support is
not compact okay so this is just like a
physicist calculation and here it's
clear that our we you should think of it
as something of all the square root n
okay that's the ball which contains most
of the mass of a Gaussian so let's
assume those two thing then few lines of
algebra really simple show to you that
in this case if you take this kernel
then you get that the expectation of PT
t squared is bounded by exponential ten
times lambda R squared okay this is
simple
really I'm not hiding anything just a
few lines so given this what we want is
this thing to be a constant R squared is
going to be of order n so you need to
take lambda to be of order 1 over n ok
so with lambda of order 1 over N we get
following our regret yes yes
so lambda is coming in in the kernel in
the definition of the kernel yeah
so lambda is coming in the definition of
the core should be equal to lambda core
okay so the cob depends on lambda here I
explained you know for different values
of lambda I get a different core and
when lambda is more the core gets
smoother okay
so you get four different values of
lambda you get a different car and the
core is what you use to define the
kernel and the kernel is what you use to
define the unbiased estimator that
you're going to put in the exponential
with yes exact so they regret okay we're
going to use this inequality right we
get 1 over lambda times this thing and
for this thing we can use the lemma so
in the end we get 1 over lambda times
the regret that we would get with L
tilde so that's n log t over Etta +
ecchi okay I get a Totti here because I
made sure that the variance with lambda
for the 1 over N the variance is a
further 1 so if I optimize over Etta and
Nanda is 1 over n what I get is this is
n to the 3 half square root T which I
conjecture to be the optimal thing so
that would that's that's where that's
one reason why we conjecture the end to
the three half skirt of course I'm
making those crazy assumptions which are
not true good so let's do I have to say
also that most of the work comes after
this okay so this we added last year and
then most of the work was to fix one and
two so I will call it fix one and two
but this is where most of the paper
actually is ok so let's do fix one
because it would be nice if exponential
ways we're Gaussian but exponential
weights are not caption so what we do
instead is the following so you see here
I said that I wanted this inequality
star and I said okay star when K when
the kernel is like this it's satisfied
if Z is equal to KP but in fact it's
enough that Z is convex li dominated by
KP for star we only need
the Z is convex Li dominated by K P this
is convex domination convex domination
just means that when I integrate Z
against any convex function the value
that I get is smaller that when I
integrate this convex function against K
P okay that's all we need over there
so in particular using this observation
it's easy to see that if we have
something which is convex D dominated by
P and we take the core of this then we
get stuff so in particular
if Q is convexity dominated by P and Z
we take it to be the core of Q so we
have Q's is we have P is the exponential
weight we take Q which is something
which is smaller inside the exponential
weights and take Z to be the core of Q
then you get stuff
okay that's again just a few lines of
algebra so the only thing that I need to
show to to use those equations is
basically to prove that inside any P is
inside any P which is given by
exponential weight there is a small
gumption there is a Gaussian which is
convex T dominated so this is the
content of the following lemma so if P
is isotropic law concave this is another
place where we use low concavity where
we use convexity but presumably it
shouldn't be really needed so why is
exponential wait slow concave so it's
not exactly luck okay but it's
approximately local cave what I put in
the in the exponential weights is the
sum of the LTTE which should be close to
the sum of the LP the sum of the LT is a
convex function so if I can prove
concentration and I can prove it because
by induction the variance of the
previous terms are controlled okay so
the proof is going to be by induction
the previous variants are controlled so
I know that my son of activity is close
to the sum of the LT which is a convex
function so P is close to being low
concave so if P is isotropic and not
concave then what you can show is that a
Gaussian centered at 0 and with with
variance 1 over N times the identity so
you lose in the dimension this is
convexity dominated approximately convex
lis dominated by P okay it's
approximately dominated by P why is
approximate because there is some mass
at infinity that can be annoying but
this can be dealt with it's not a big
deal
that's a fix to one so what it means in
the grand scheme of thing is that you
get your exponential weights you find a
small Gaussian inside it then you take
the core of this more Gaussian this is
also Gaussian and using this Gaussian
you get the kernel
what is this kernel is the density of
the core so this density is a gap is a
Gaussian and in fact you can see that
it's the tail of the Gaussian so what it
means is that we are estimating convex
functions by piecing together tales of
Gaussian distributions I think it's
impossible to get at this point you know
just directly I mean it came out of all
of this but why it works in particular
in the tail of the Gaussian you know
it's it's it's close to being linear so
in fact again coming back to what I was
saying at the beginning there is a sense
in which we are trying to be used a
program to the leaner case but you have
to change thank God
yes we are changing the algorithm in
play in particular we are not playing
from the exponential weights were
playing from KT PT so from the kernel
applied to this okay and let me conclude
with the in the last five minutes with
the fixed - - is actually almost the
most tricky part so you really need this
fact that it's compact
yeah rescale things so that P is
isotropic it has covariance one so it
means you know eventually the
exponential weights are going to focus
on some region so the valence is going
to be very small so what it means when I
say that is that the support is on this
small region so what it means is I will
never play outside of this small region
but this can be terrible in the address
or setting because the adversary can
make me focus on the small region and
then move the optimum outside so what we
are going to do is that we going to have
a condition that we check to verify that
the adversary is not moving outside and
if the adversary moves outside then we
start the algorithm and what we need to
show that when we restart we have
negative regret actually so you can
forget about all the phases where we
restarted and this negative regret will
come from the difference of entropies
okay so let me try to explain this
okay so let's let F G so f G is going to
be our focus region
it's the ellipse containing most of the
mass so one minus one over T to the
tenth day of the mass of P G
so this is the ellipse that contains
most of the mass and to truncate the
exponential weights what we're going to
say is that the loss outside of this
focus region is infinite to truncate
set entity to be plus infinity on the
compliment of ft okay so the picture is
like this this is a this is K and we
have zoomed on some region right we keep
intersecting ellipses and this is our
current focus region so outside we have
zero probability mass so the issue is
simply that the estimator is not
unbiased everywhere so we cannot control
the the regret with respect to points
outside but we can ensure that the
minimum of the sum of the losses is
always inside like this so the key
observation one key observation is that
the minimum of the sum of the LT is in
is some of the LS for s equals 1 to t is
in ft provided that
if I look at the minimum of the sum of
the estimator until des for X in the
boundary of F T and I compare this to
the minimum in F T if this is large
enough namely if this is omega of 1 over
the learning rate okay so what I'm
saying is I look at the minimum of my
scimitar inside the convex region and
the minimum on the boundary if the
minimum of the boundary is high enough
then by concentration I know that also
the minimum of the true loss on the
boundary is above the minimum of the
true loss inside and then by convexity
it can only go up you know outside of
the focus region so if I have this
condition then I know that the minimum
is in F G so as long as this is
satisfied I can keep shrinking it
doesn't matter the problem is if this
becomes violated then it could be that
the adversary is moving outside so if
star is violated
let's say by some X in the boundary of
ft then we restart
Marisol and want to say okay when we
restart we have negative regret we only
need to show negative regret with
respect to this point so let's say this
is the point X you know at some point in
the past it was a bad point it's on the
boundary so it means that at some point
in the past it was on the boundary of
this ellipse so it means that the
estimated loss was huge very large okay
so let let me denote by s the time the
first time T such that X is in the
boundary of 50 okay so this is the first
time that X entered in this region at
this time the loss was big so in
particular if I look at the relative
entropy of the point mass at X with
respect to p1 minus the relative entropy
of Delta X with respect to P s this is
huge it's huge hugely negative so let's
think about it so at the beginning p1 is
uniform and at time s PS is is this
exponential wait and it has very small
mass on the point X so the relative
entropy here is much bigger than this
one so this term is negative so in the
in the regret we get a negative regret
with respect to this point that's great
but that's only at time s if you know
the proof of the lemma that I showed to
you there is a telescopic sum right
that's how this term appears so if I
continue this term is going to telescope
with with the next entropies so what you
need to avoid this telescoping is to
increase the learning rate to avoid
telescoping
and what I mean by this is we want to
keep this term in the regret bomb
because this is going to be the term
that helped us to guess negative regret
to avoid telescoping we need to have a
learning rate which depends on time and
at time t plus 1 s at time t plus 1 s
plus 1 sorry you want to multiply by 1
plus gamma it is so usually in learning
we have a decreasing learning rate not
always okay Sasha for instance of the
paper with increasing learning right but
usually you have a decreasing learning
rate so here you need to increase the
learning rate basically you think I
increase the running rate so that I'm
more careful and I can catch any
movement of the adversary more rapidly
okay good that's good the issue is that
you cannot do that all the time if you
always augment by 1 plus gamma you know
after tea time step you have augmented
by 1 plus gamma to the T which is huge
so you can only do this from time to
time so the next idea and final idea is
that you don't update the focus region
all the time you only update the focus
region when it really matters ok so only
update ft
if updating decreases the volume of the
focus region decreases volume of 50 so
what I mean by this is you currently
have a focus region and let's say the
new ellipse is like this it's just
cutting a little bit of mass here and a
little bit of mass here so in what I
said before this would be my new focus
region but this is bad because I'm
updating too often so what I'm going to
say is that I only update when the scale
of the problem is changing so if at some
point the ellipse is really like this
and I need to remove all of this and all
of this then I will do the update namely
if when the volume of the updated region
is less than 1/2 of the total volume
then I update and if I update then I
increase the learning rate so basically
what I'm doing is when I see that the
scale of the problem has changed then I
amend the learning rate so that I'm
being more careful if the adversary's
moving up and if I see that the
adversary is moving out so you need so
you cannot see that from what I
explained you need to work out you know
the value of lambda and really what what
is the KT that comes out of this because
I didn't write it right now right K T of
X Y it's not really the density of Z or
anything like that it's really the
density of so it's X minus lambda Y
divided by 1 minus lambda and this
lambda Y is pushing in the tail it's
changing the balance
this you need to write it down to see it
and what it really means is that this
term here is really using the tail of
the Gaussian what I mean by that is what
kind of why are you putting in here
you're not putting any kind of why
you're putting wise which are here
in the current focus region and if you
look at the scale of those wise with
respect to the scale of something that
you put in here you would see that
you're in the tail of the Gaussian
you say why is it efficient yeah so I
mean the worst point in all of this is
this checking the restart condition
because I'm minimizing okay something
which is not convex but almost convex on
the boundary of a convex set so this is
an NPR problem so what you can do is you
can really replace ellipses by
hypercubes and then you just need to
minimize over the faces of cubes and you
are polynomially many faces and so it's
all fine then the fact that you're not
something from a lot concave but
something approximately low concave ok
rabbika none and these friends I did
that you know 20 years ago so you can do
that but the what does it mean exactly
approximately row concave it's pretty
delicate in particular what we get is we
get instead of n to the 9.5 we get n to
the 10.5 if you want something efficient
and uh okay just one last thing which is
a bit hidden in the paper a stupid thing
which is delicate also is to calculate
QT @xt the density at this point so what
you need to do is to do repeated
sampling of those things to estimate
this density because you don't have a
closed form formula for this so what we
do actually is we do a Taylor
approximation of this density and we
just keep the first few terms that the
last part when is the last one
let's take other questions offline